好吧 我開始說吧
然後那個上週其實我覺得是這樣吧
就是我發現我可一點
然後我主要因為這是個騰訊會議嘛
所以我主要還是講一下那個產業吧
我就今天花時間講一下產業
因為上一週其實我們說到CPU可能會缺貨
那CPU中間如何的缺貨
包括AI產業現在市場的這個預期差在哪裡
就是我總結了三個比較大的預期差吧
我覺得就是三個階段預期差
我待會跟大家說一下
就我認為AI產業預期差
然後這週其實沒有特別多的經濟數據吧
Weekend的這傢伙被抓了
然後我覺得不太想講太多
就是你們可以關注一下那個
現代戰爭的模式的改變
就是我們到時候可以專題說一下這個事情
就是以Palantir為主的
就是戰爭的模式的改變
但是這個東西呢
他們對那個外匯在今年
我覺得是會有一些影響
所以我覺得先講一下經驗大致的宏觀
然後補充上週的情況再說一下關於CPU缺貨
就是CPU就是AMD和Intel的那個CPU缺貨
然後特別是我說一下我們週末
其實有幾個有幾個行業內的會吧
大家對於存儲的一些看法
就是對於存儲資產的看法
不是對於存儲本身缺貨看法
這個東西是沒有什麼意義的
先說一下那個一些Global News
就這個星期應該是只有星期五的時候的
就業數據是比較重要的
其他的話那個數據方面沒有特別的多動想
雖然說是週末的時候
有一些Geopolitical的這個
就是我們叫做地緣政治的一些變化
地緣政治的一些事件吧
那麼其實馬杜羅被抓了
然後最後中天發生了什麼樣一些陰謀性的事件
但是至少宣示了一件事情
就是美國在北美的絕對的
北美不是北美
在美洲的絕對的統治權
所以這個和我待會講到
就是市場的三個幾個影響中間
一個外匯是比較有關係的
就是我們其實從2024年
就2024年的年底的時候
其實我記得挺早以前這一年多以前
然後我們提到過一個概念
就是資金的回流當時就開始
其實在2025年第二季度左右
就是這個事情變加劇了
因為特朗普上臺的時候
大家又有一輪對於美國改革
這個共和黨上臺以後
pro-business這些樂觀
但是很快特朗普宣布了一些關稅
然後這個資金的回流又開始
變得比較距離
其實我們看2025年的整個週期裡面
就是我們先說一下紅瓜
那個2025年整個週期裡面
走得好的不光是中國股票
是全世界的很多資產都做得不錯
就是我們叫2023年和2024年是Decouple
就是全世界所有的增長吧
就是疫情之後沒多久
那個全世界所有的增長以美國為領頭
就是大家發現其他地方
沒有什麼增長的動力
疫情剛過去
然後生產沒有恢復
消費其實消費
消費因為這個大家抗通脹
所以這個利率很高
所以沒有很大的增長的點
增長點在AI在美國
所以其實2024年的市場
特別2023年底
2024年的市場基本上都是
以美國以AI高科技我們會追問
2025年的市場有點不一樣
2025年市場從2024年底開始
我們經歷了一輪資金的從美國的回流
所以導致全世界包括EM
包括歐洲
包括日本包括中國全部在場
那個現在就是一個叫
我們叫做重新recover的過程
我叫他recover
就重新掛鉤的一過程
就是美國的增長
帶動了全球的其他地方增長
但是其實也有每個地方
在追的一些行為吧
包括歐洲近2024年底
看出大規模的CAPEX
然後中國從2024年底開始
把基礎貨幣直接印了
超過了一倍
那個M2沒有增加那麼多
那麼再增加
但是基礎貨幣給他們增加了一倍
所以這是一個非常瘋狂的印錢
包括在日本都是一樣的
所以大家我們其實25年有一個
25年26年吧
就是包括今年是全球的
我們叫physical大周期
就是財政大周期
大家都在應付的在印錢
但是真正的增長和科技增長在哪裡呢
科技增長
真正的增長還是在美國
所以我就借周末的事情來說一下
我對宏觀的一個
就是特別大的一個宏觀的一個看法
就是2024年是decapel
2025年是recapel
2027年至少在2026年年中以後
又是要decapel
因為這個和我們在AI或投資上面看到的
這個預期差
我們一直講預期差
就是為什麼我當好會說不要去炒存儲
炒存儲風險比較大
那個就是他把預期差打滿
在中國日本歐洲的預期差
是幾乎是沒有的
美國預期差是負的
就是美國的就負面的預期很大
包括對他的去年年底
對他的財政政策
今年的那個中期選舉的時候的那個
不確定性的影響
對吧
包括其實美股的
你說美股固執
美股固執一點都不高
我當好會說一下AI的固執
為什麼不算很高
雖然它中間有這麼多的不確定性
它確實有很多的風險在
但是這個預期差跟歐洲和
資金回流的預期差跟歐洲和中國不太一樣
那麼中國人民幣在升值
一直在升
中國因為從我們說一下外匯吧
就是外匯
所以這個事情的
這個事情中間有一個反應
就是外匯在去年美元是在下跌的
美元下跌對所有貨幣
就對人民幣
包括你看黃金長成這個樣子
央行是一個原因
但是美元下跌也很重要
因為美元在下跌
美元其實現在已經
我叫它進不完全是石油美元
美元現在很大程度上已經是
已經是美股美元
所以它和美股是比較寡垢的
就是我不認為就是因為
這個考慮性比較高
就是資金再從美國流出來
但是
美股是估值過高
而是美股在美元資金流出的時候
仍然因為它的盈利維持了比較堅定
我覺得應該這樣解釋比較好
因為在2025年年初和2026年年初
現在美國的S&P大概是22倍到23倍吧
這個估值沒有特別大的變化
它是成靠自己盈利打出來的
就增長上去的
這和中國股市有那麼一點區別
不是中國吧
就是美國以外的股市是有那麼一點區別
就是雖然你不能只看估值和p的
你得看它盈利和增長和它的這個產業
所以我倒是想反覺得就是26年美元
會走到一個就是26年年建在這個時點
美元在一個底部區間
你不能說它26年這個美元會
會漲多少
因為美國畢竟還在降旗的通道裡面
但是降旗已經被預期進去了
所以至少有一部分pricing美國霸權喪失的人
包括美國政治上胡搞
是美元不知道走到哪裡的人
會就是在26年的時候會回頭
就是在26年的這個基本面上
我覺得至少我的一個market sense
我覺得美元現在在底部
所以作為和美元資產掛鉤的
coloration很強的美國股票啊
風險資產
它應該是在26年面臨資金再度回流
再回去
不確定性在中期選舉前後會慢慢消退
會有不確定性的發生
但是這個不確定性就是有一定的定價了
現在市場上有一定定價
這是我對於宏觀就是貨幣上的看法
那確實你說美國有沒有風險
那美國肯定還是有風險的
就整個市場還是有風險
包括我覺得更大程度上是
不完全是因為AI的寶寶
更大程度上其實是因為
geopolitical就是中期選舉
美國相對來說兩黨
然後我們也不清楚
委內瑞拉的事情背後有什麼樣的交換
所以這個交換背後
如果說有其他的動作的話呢
那就會對市場造成很大的衝擊
這個我就不額外多說
那麼但是在不確定性的中間的
確定性是AI現在被定價還是偏低
AI的adoption還沒有完全上的
所以我說一下這個預期差
就是我們在做投資的時候
比較重要都是看這個預期的差
就是我覺得先說一下AI吧
AI整個行業裡面
我覺得是三個就是現在的預期
和定價在一個比較低的位置
我說一下華爾街怎麼想的
華爾街的人想法是這樣的
就是今年你的CAPEX確實沒有問題
5350億預期
5350億的預期
然後我看你這個CAPEX相關
這些公司能賺多少錢
很清晰
大家都知道你能賺多少錢
那補向A股裡面
能夠看到這個東西
之後就把新醫生和中級局上
炒到天上去
因為這個盈利今年能看得到
然後明年有沒有不知道
但是華爾街不是這麼看
它就覺得你
那你明年能賺這個錢嗎
你的CAPEX才能增加嗎
那你這個CAPEX對於一人
比方說一千多塊錢在美國
那你能不能夠增加多少呢
一千五百塊錢吧
美國三億人口
然後從這個角度來講
我認為你這個CAPEX才27年來8年
沒辦法延續
然後我給你的定價相對來說比較低
那這個對比有點像當年造鐵路的時候
就是你從東海岸到西海岸造條鐵路
沒人用的
所以我不認為你現在沒有人用
你這個鐵路造完以後
那個你投資收益可能收不回來
你現在再做CAPEX可以
我把你鋼廠先炒上去
炒一炒可以
但是我對這件事情
東西鐵路需要運輸需要人
需要這個東西
需要那個能夠帶動產業
我不認可
其實現在AI就分成華爾街的一些
質疑盤和硅谷的
你就相信看
就是你你如果是
就但是市場交易呢
又森浩在中間
就是你如果是不相信AI的
那你應該是認為
包括英偉大的固執是過高的
那所有包括存儲
包括狂魔塊
包括你CPU
包括所有東西
你應該全部雜保
就是這個東西
不會存在
那麼如果是相信AI能夠帶來
就是
我是相信到
就是能夠帶來比方說
不是說
能夠帶來效率的增加吧
你看
adoption rate會繼續增加的話
那麼其實現在呢
其實你不會覺得AI在一個泡沫上面
因為
我覺得舉個例子是這樣說的
就是說我們AI真正在應用的人
就好像拿火車
真正在運貨的人
是前端的那些在做PE的公司
和前端的那些公司
現在市場定價的
預期差在
我們是按照最低的
CAPEX在定價
就是那個投資
每年的投資在定價
那麼這個CAPEX在定價是今年
比方說增加30%
那過去每年
它其實預期都是20 30
然後最後增加了50
那麼我們現在所有的股票的估值
比方說因為拿這些股票估值
都是按照30在定價
就是我CAPEX是最低
然後給你一個R6 27年28年
我不確定
然後給你一個相對來說比較低的PE
現在是這樣定的價
比方說因為它是今年年底
可能按照Covos的現成
就是台積電的那個柳片的這個現成
看的話
它可能是
因為大概是9塊9塊5
9塊2到9塊5
那麼現在180
今天109了
109就是20倍PE
20倍左右的PE
大概是這麼給你定的價
但是其實這是第一個
第一個就是它真正的CAPEX
可能會增加的
那個缺貨的情況
沒有被完全Pricing
特別是CPU和GPU上的缺貨
它Pricing是廣播化和存儲
這個是比較前端的
所以這個邏輯就是很混亂
就是你既然已經不選擇
不相信Ai
不相信那個英偉達
能夠後面不停的缺貨
那你怎麼敢去給最最容易
擴產的存儲去給它這麼高的定價
而且現在給到不是HBM
它是給到了Ned
給到了那個Ned存儲
最最通用的存儲
所以這個定價
其實在市場上是有一些分裂
但是對於大票
除了大的Ai的產業
他們的定價沒有那麼過分
所以這是一
其實第二個
我覺得是
這座Ai要Boost Productivity elsewhere
就是讓其他地區的
其他公司的這個生產效率
要再提高
那這個其實在市場上
現在剛剛看到出頭
但沒有很明確的看到
因為你看這個相當於
也是這個Ai的Adoptinger
有多少人在用這個付費的Ai的模式
就是付費的Ai模式
那你可以看到
IT是最對指標
因為它可以把它幫你變成
等於可以把你寫文章
你每天IT的工作
你可以認為就是能拿程序去寫文章
那Ai能寫文章
大家就是直接可能應用
Financial是沒有那麼直接
但是呢
Financial這一塊呢
是人工成本最高的
所以大家
比方說我原來寫郵件
我可以老闆寫郵件
每天花幾個小時寫郵件
想好錯字怎麼寫
不能寫錯筆字
然後現在這個郵件
NLS的郵件基本上都是Ai寫的
然後以前花PC都需要直接定格
我再給你們看一個
這個是我們昨天內部開會
討論完那個關於Ai的投資機會之後
這個拿會計要拿那個
應該這個是拿谷歌吧
拿節目來去生成的這個BBT
這些工作就是從NLS角度來說
都已經不太需要了
所以這些Adoption Rate
現在還相對的是
你看現在還是很低
但是這些Adoption Rate會變高的
就是我們第二步的預期長
你至少要看到哪個公司
能夠因為IT高他們的效率
現在我們已經看到了金融行業已經有
但是市場都沒有定價
包括有一些很少公司
CHRW這些CH Robinson
那些他再被更好的
就是他是做物流的
然後讓那個AI幫他去提高了效率
所以我們看到是非常有限的案例
那麼第三個預期長
我覺得更加沒有定價的是
就是AI的公司本身利用AI
做出新的行業
比方說我們說到就是
團隊之前看的一個公司叫Hobby的
叫Hobby's
他是可能我們預期他四個人
五個人的律所
然後通過AI搶佔
比方說以後搶佔全美10%的律師的生意
這個我覺得是很正常的
就好像現在那個二水晶計劃
就Mercury的那個計劃
就OpenAI裡面可能顧了一堆搞金融的人
花花錢顧了一堆搞金融的人
一共就花了3000多萬美元
他已經把能夠投行做的事情全部完成
就包括Vispectives
這行全不可以完成
然後那律師的生意
是不是可能幾個人的團隊
以後就把那個
百分之幾的市場分合搶下來
我覺得這個也是很容易的
因為有很多失誤性的事情
他就是可以做的
就是現在AI行業裡面
最後我們說他能不能夠有泡沫
就是他能不能維持著CAPEX
去決於有沒有人給他投錢
那投錢人的心理是怎麼樣的
投錢的心理是說
我把錢給到你這個出創點
說五個人十個人團隊
不管你估值是多少
我讓你去搶掉原來的生意
所以AI提高效率的同時
很多人會死掉的
但是他是能夠持續獲得現金流嗎
我們至少從PE和規模投資來看
包括OpenAI的投資
包括很多這些PE的那些
受惠的那些AI agent的公司投資
我們不覺得在明年27年28年
就是至少不會覺得27年的投資會停下來
就是他是這個這些家伙們在用
所有上市的公司其實
不管它是Neviden
Neviden也好
包括Mahoso的AWS
Amazon他們也好
他們其實都是賣產子的
所以這個是我們現在看到的AI產業
就是這個三個是預期差
第二個只在某些小部分的上市公司中間看到
第三部分
就第三部分我們叫做AI真正使用出來的場景
就是我們在第三第四季度
其實現在上市的就是Palantir和Tampus AI
大家覺得比較確定
因為Tampus AI有醫療的數據
Palantir有國防部的訂單
這個家伙搞不好就被Palantir給抓了
因為它本身就是做每個人的定位
就是現代打仗的模式
就說一句吧
現在打仗的模式的改變
就是現在打仗模式的變化
是因為我們斬首了
都是包括以色列和伊朗打
都是找到那個領導讓領導先走
就不是豪顧戰把小兵打死
是二戰的時候
坦克部隊繞到後面把你指揮部朝掉
現在打仗是先讓領導先走
所以這個就是比方說只有Tampus
和那個Tampus AI和那個Palantir
但是其實沒有看到大規模其他的跑出來
我覺得什麼時候到了可能有泡沫呢
就是要到第三步
就是你不敢相信的東西
都有很多人在相信
然後都在投這個東西
然後就講故事是有人性的
就好像00年的時候
你去講互聯網的故事
我弄個網站講故事是有人性的
現在你賣產值的人
都是按照你最最保守的呼吸
明年會有多少產值賣得掉
那麼來氣算
所以我就覺得整體的
從AR角度來說
固執上沒有很大的就是
沒有沒有看到很大的泡沫
但相比較就是說
整個行業裡面也要分細分
你要在中期續上和新一新一生這種公司裡面
不講中國的話
就比方說你在那個Romant
比方說昨天光幕過期的第二段
Romant或Sandex上面下很重的住的話
那我覺得其實這個是有風險
因為確實明年的宏觀有一個特點
就是明年的宏觀
這可能聖浩是一個相對樂觀的特點
就是明年的宏觀是
我這個圖在哪裡
就業率會比較差
但是GDP不會特別大
就我Summarize
我之前一直講過這個事情
所以導致的是這種情況下
導致的是Corporate earning比較好
第一個Corporate earning比較好
因為GDP不差
第二個就是就業比較差
就是你的本身公司的成本沒有很高
但是就業比較差
同時的話會讓美聯儲和國家
就是Federal Fiscal Policy比較激進
所以這是一個宏觀上
能夠推動的一個狀況原因
但是為什麼我說
我們去覺得在純處高位的時候
去看純處不太合適
在光幕塊特別樂觀的時候
去看光幕塊也是比較有風險的
因為它的行業是相對來說比較容易複產的
就是我覺得去敦純處
去買純處不留去敦CPU
CPU這個事情我們上次講過
其實很多人在認為CPU有問題的時候
是覺得HBM加上GPU
這個PPT是AI化的問題
就是你們想想這個AI能夠以後能做的事情
這是我們一個半小時
兩個小時吧
兩個小時電話會說完全是AI化
就是很多人認為GPU加HBM
能夠把那個CPU給取代掉
但其實並不是這樣的
如果說GPU加HBM把CPU取代掉
DDR也沒有需求了
那就以後全部GPU加HBM計算就好了
首先這個東西散熱是很麻煩的
真正在技術上是很難就完成純粹的GPU加GPU
第二現在市場上真正缺貨的就是缺了DDR5
DDR5X的那個服務器就缺了DDR
所以DDR可能和HBM用的是一個流片的線
那你可以把這個當成GPU和HBM的外掛
為了這個圖畫對不了
我也不是直接做DWE的
但是現在你最新的那個服務器
DDR5X服務器上面有12個CPU上有12個那個碰到
你就這樣理解
就是我用原來的CPU肯定是不行的
因為我現在服務器需要的那個內存越來越大了
那麼現在一條都是兩T嘛
然後我用內存越來越大
那個最新的那個可能是8盒CPU
然後每盒加12條等於有96條
96條通道
那個你不可能用老的CPU
所以真正缺貨缺在哪裡缺在最新的CPU現成上面
但CPU現成有沒有那麼容易被
就是CPU現成有沒有那麼容易那個破產
那個炒Sandex和炒Sandex我能夠理解為什麼
就是說你可以把DDR就是這樣的關係
我跟你說
你可以把DDR當成HBM的外掛
但是炒到NAND就炒到第三層的存儲上面的
這個其實不太確定
就是你現在是希望說AI agent應用的時候
然後大家以後有每個人都確定很大的儲存需求
每個人都會把這個東西
就等於我每次我應用
比方我上次會議中間講到
比方說我在用協成上
我在找酒店通過我的位置生存的信息
然後存在那個Pay了美的存在
不同User ID的信息給它存下去
但是是否NAND的需求會定價
變成HBM的需求的實位
這個是賞心要定價的
但是這個事情確實是有不確定性
所以你在存儲上面
而且這個東西擴產到了兩年三年以後
真的是可以擴展成commodity商品
也就是說光模塊和存儲都是這樣
就這兩年它們瘋狂的賺錢
是有可能後面會虧錢
然後真正的AI上的GoKeeper
就是手文員是誰
是TSMC
因為只有它能夠留CPU和GPU
CPU Intel也能留
等那個產量沒有它大
但是真正只能夠留片的是只有它
就是它的擴產是非常控制的
這個我們可以過去看得到
它就是比方說40%的這個CAPEX
CAPEX就是40%左右
你雖然說那個Covos的現成
就是Covos現成在27年的預期
26年預期提高了嘛
但是本質上我是覺得TSMC是看到了
整個市場有巨大的海量的需求
它根據這個海量需求
後退的給出了值得CAPEX和產量
所以它是手文員
它是AI包括了手文員
它持續的讓半導體一直在缺貨
但是大盤中國能做的東西
就我覺得比方說長星長城都能做的東西
後面不一定能夠缺貨
就不一定缺貨的意思就是後面的那個
不知道缺貨不怎麼樣
就是存儲的需求有可能會很大
它可能繼續缺貨
缺到27年
那就意味著MU現在的位置
可能是6倍
6倍匹
然後反2倍
反1倍
我覺得很正常可以
但是中間你的持估體驗會比較差
就是它的持估體驗差在就
舉個例子
我長星長城上市了
它確實說自己能做HPM
那肯定做不了
但是它上市以後
它說它能
然後做出很大的產能
市場上的嘴資們
我現在有個詞叫嘴資
就是大家用嘴在吵我
昨天晚上光播或砸盤
就是嘴資們砸的
可能潮信一聲
四季度營利沒有那麼好
好像什麼事情
我忘了
我沒有Velcro
我不確定這個事情
但是
嘴資可以說
中國後面產能很大
你的馬就沒有那麼高
那隨時就可以給你
給你回調一個很深的幅度
回調下來
所以就是
我是覺得
至少在今年吧
26年
性價比就風險性價比來說
雖然成熟長得很兇
風險性價比來說
我是覺得CPU的確定性
是很高很高的
因為你就看我們
AI幫我們畫這畫
CPU原來是這樣
它需要的這個通道
這個叫通道
它通道沒有那麼多
卡沒有那麼多
現在這12個通道了
12個通道你必須
得養允心的CPU
這個CPU的缺貨
整個CPU和CPU
還有個TSMC
在控制的
它控制的產能
GPU的產能就Covas的產能
它其實是一直控制的
我們本質上就是說
因為你如果說GPU都不缺貨了
那光碰化還有什麼用
對吧
這東西也沒有用了
GPU缺貨是
所有東西AI的根本
GPU缺貨背後就是
OpenAI有沒有投資
其他AI Aging有沒有投資
所以我剛剛講的就是
我認為OpenAI
後面AI Aging
都是有投資的
所以GPU肯定會缺貨
那GPU缺貨是
怎麼看它缺貨
就看它去年造了多少
數據中心
然後能放多少張卡
今年造多少數據中心
它能放多少張卡
去年缺貨300萬張
今年缺貨400萬張
27年產能Covas上去
還是缺貨
所以這個才是
因為它業績
非常確定的本質
就是在今年年底
它會看到明年年底
還是缺貨
它能產多少
能賣多少
然後又有TSMC
作為一個GoKeeper
就是TSMC
就是整個行業的這個
製造給你一直短缺
它跟英偉達的關係
是非常鐵的
那麼我最後滑5分鐘說一下
最後滑5分鐘
就重申一下
為什麼像英偉達
這樣的公司
它會慢慢取代
比方說Cocom
現在就廢了吧
就是我們叫做
手機端
或者是端和語音
語音的那個芯片設計公司
要替代掉端口的設計公司
因為它能付更多的錢
就是英偉達
它一個NV720
應該300多萬美元吧
它300多萬美元裡面
這個芯片
就本身這個
比起的芯片
它的成本相對是比較低的
所以它能夠接受漲價
而手機你沒有辦法
再接受漲價
這是第二個
算力的需求
就是AR時代
你很多的算力
其實你想
都已經替代到語音上面去了
所以有可能導致的是
大家原來每一年
這個跟包括內存的
內存的這個產線
現在產線都是1920年出來的
就是跟內存的那個產線
是一樣的
就是我的手機
更新疊帶的速度
一直在下降
包括在現在時候
包括過去幾年
一直在下降
就疊帶的速度在下降
所以手機廠
為什麼都要去坐車呢
因為手機疊帶速度下降了
產能過剩了
它麻將在降低
中國手機廠麻將在5%
疊帶下降
是因為大家可能
不需要這麼高級的芯片
芯片N2和N3的芯片
的差距
就是成本差距
可能要差一倍
也差很多
所以以後
我們AR使用表說
用恰吉DPC說話
它的算力
只在語音裡面完成
並不一定需要
手機用到
這麼高端的芯片
就原來
所有高端芯片設計
都是以手機端來發起的
誰能夠做
比方說誰能夠做
先進行製程的芯片
都是看你手機
然後看蘋果
蘋果先流出來
然後蘋果用完了
給Corecom和MTK
那後面不是這樣子
就是後面可能就是
端口的就是
英偉達他們
包括其他
為數據中心設計的芯片
它的能夠獲得麻將更高
從上週
其實我講過這個事情
上週你從內存的
MU的戰略
你就能看得到
MU把消費電子的產能
全給你切掉
我可以不竭你手機
手機廠的聲音
我還用不做你的聲音
汽車廠的聲音
你愛搶貨
你自己搶貨去
跟我沒有關係
我就做毛利率比較高的
數據中心的聲音
就是我就賣給數據中心
數據中心廠60% 70%
那個
那個應該新的
價錢廠70% 70%
那個就是地利亞
然後
所以我是覺得
這樣是一個趨勢
所以就回到我們整體
資產配承
上週我們講過這個事情
新資產配承
我是覺得今年比較安全的
在這兩個資產
這兩個資產
是有可能這個暴漲
你可以在暴跌的時候去抄底
但是
不太合適去追高的
就這個風險是有的
然後
Geopolitical
各種方面都有風險
然後
真正的泡沫出現
是要等到
AI agent的泡沫出現
就是比方說
歐盟AI上市
然後他已經炒到
7萬億
5萬億之類的
然後這種時候
你才能認為是
或者是
我不知道
把Tampas炒幾倍
Palantir
是因為軍工的理由
這個不能完全算
比方說你
你搞個綠鎖的
應用AI
然後這個被炒到天上去
之類的
有這種的操作的時候
你才認為是有泡沫
我覺得
現在預計差在美國
還是很明顯
大家定價很
很謹慎
安照的是非常基礎的定價
定價
這個我講一下
對市場的看法
然後我看看
我還有點時間
我看看大家有什麼問題
我額外再說一個
就是
Bcoin
最近長得比較多
然後
我跟幣圈一些
大的資金談的話
其實大資金
我身邊大資金
還是沒有賣幣的
所以
我之前就說
這個推動
後面推動的很大的動力就是
這是一個
你可以認為有一點
操控的市場
但是這個市場中間
所有大玩家
從8萬多開始
其實都在
一直在買和看多
就這一輪跌下去
那你要想到
他這一輪跌下去的
一個很重要的原因是
MSDR被
被重intox裡面
可能會移掉
但是2月份之後
確定移掉之後
他有點那個
利空出境的感覺
所以
BTC肯定是
我們現在是不能
過去看空打
就是
好
看看他有什麼問題